ط
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله اما بعد يقول
الحافظ النووي في رياضه في باب التوبه
في سياق حديث ابي سعيد الخدري الطويل
في ذكر قاتل ال 99 نفسا
‏in
ابو سعيد الخدري رضي الله عنه
which is repentance which is often what
is most looked
‏other
manur
souls
taken 99 lives and s out the knowledable
‏available to ask him whether or not he
was eligible for repentance if he could
repent after such atrocities and he was
directed to a monk a person who in all
for all intents and purposes was a
righteous individual someone who
worships Allah subhanahu waala
‏ofous and
uping
that
was
this man was to him however this monk
made a fatal mistake not just for
himself not just for this man but also
for society at large.
لما نذكر
اشد الخطر على الانسان ما هو الذي يضاد
العلم المضاداه التامه هل هو الجاهل لا
الجهل
هو داء صحيح داء قاتل لكن له شفاء شفاؤه
السؤال كما قال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
انما شفاء العي السؤال هكذا قال شفاء العي
الجهل
المشكله الجهل المركب ما هو الجهل المركب
يقول الاصوليون الجهل المركب
هو او على عباره العلماء هو الجاهل الذي
يجهل
انه جاهل
فاي شفاء لهذا
الجهل البسيط
عند الاصوليين
‏ised
rather easily
knowledge ignorance
the real enemy to knowledge is
compounded ignorance what is compounded
ignorance compounded ignorance is a
person who is ignorant but is unaware
that he is ignorant he is ignorant but
is deluded into thinking that he knows
this is
‏Why? Because how can you some
impossible it's a upside down and
putting it under the under the to get a
glass of water. How can you fill it up?
It's impossible. And so this man
was not just ignorant but he was
suffering of compounded ignorance.
‏Because if was regular
when the man asked him I have killed 99
kill 99 people
can repent would
I don't know
this
answered unit
‏and
if we understand the true fall of
compounded ignorance this send a little
shiver up our spine
because not just of the ignorance or of
the compounded nature of this ignorance
but the confidence
that a person of compounded ignorance
has.
‏spe لا فقتله فكمل به المئه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ثم سال عن اعلم اهل الارض فدل على رجل
عالم
فقال انه قتل 100 نفس فهل له من توبه
فقال نعم
ومن يحول بينه وبين التوبه
‏And then the man
bad again and consci wasing him again
and so gave it another shot he asked
again about the knowledable person on
now the sitation is worse than it was
before for all parties involved and this
time he was directed to a schar
and he came to him and asked him he is
killed
‏could
answer
yes of
what stand between you andent
and as will he in another
ofent
‏and
that
will neveros
بها اناساون
فاعبد الله معهم ولا ترجع الى ارضك فانها
ارض سوء
and him
also him detailed instructions as to how
to go about his repentance he said go to
such and such land a town or city or
state or whever it was go to such and
such land for indeed there
are people
الله
[Silence]
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يتقبل منا توباتنا وان يغسل حوباتنا
وان يسلل سخيمه قلوبنا اللهم امين وصل
اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين